what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we're going to be talking about a
topic that i think
a lot of people have been wondering
about for a pretty long time now
since even before avengers end game
since the disney fox deal was done and
we knew that
deadpool was coming to the mcu i think
everybody has been wondering
when is marvel disney going to start to
produce
rated r content in the mcu
and luckily for us disney has actually
answered this question
and it looks like they could have some
upcoming rated r films that are going to
take place
in the mcu and i'll talk about them in
this video and
yes deadpool is on the list in fact
deadpool is actually a
very very important property for marvel
studios in disney moving forward
and we'll talk about the streaming
service that disney is going to be
putting
deadpool and these other rated r films
on and we'll talk about and this is
going to sound
pretty weird if marvel can learn or pick
up a few things from dc
and their rated r films and a quick
reminder about my stormbreaker giveaway
all you have to do to enter subscribe to
my channel and subscribe to cosmic
culture picking a winner at the end of
this month
so rated r movies from disney may come
as
a shock to some people yes it's disney
mickey mouse the disney princesses
all of that but they do own rated r
properties and bob iger when he was the
head of disney stated that they are
going to do
rated r movies disney does indeed
release r-rated movies they're just
under other companies subsidiaries that
they happen to own to keep the disney
name clean
and that's exactly what they're going to
do here that hasn't changed for them so
the question is how exactly are we going
to be able to watch these
r rated films from disney well last year
in an
investor meeting they mentioned that
they are going to have
r-rated content or an adult or mature
rated section
on disney plus now they first stated
that it would simply be an
option that you can choose in the
settings you can go into the settings
and choose to turn
on the r rated content this would
require a password to activate so
kids wouldn't go in and do it on their
own but now it's being stated that a lot
of their adult content is going to be
on their star service on disney plus
this is where their fox properties are
going to be that are rated r
and where their hulu properties like
modoc will be on disney plus so
technically it won't fall under the
disney name so
just like how disney plus has a marvel
section a star wars section
a national geographic section they are
going to have a
star section and that's where this
content is going to be now the
exciting part what exactly is this
content
what is going to be the r rated content
of the marvel cinematic universe
well of course we have the big guy
deadpool
deadpool 3 is in development right now
and a lot of people were wondering if
it's still going to remain
rated r even though it's at disney and
luckily they have confirmed
yes it will remain a rated r franchise
and deadpool was actually a staple to
marvel studios and disney and is going
to continue to be a staple moving
forward
and the reason is because deadpool is a
movie that they couldn't get away with
making pg-13 so marvel studios and
disney faced a choice here
either compromised the character and a
lot of the things that fans
really love about the character i feel
just like a little girl
so their choice was to compromise that
or stay true to the character
and find a way to move forward now let's
be honest marvel isn't really a stranger
to
r-rated movies marvel studios is and
like i've said
disney has been making rated r films
just under other companies but marvel
has been making rated
r movies deadpool was a massive success
and it's marvel
logan was fantastic and it's still
marvel even though it's under the fox
property but still rated r and one of
the best superhero movies ever
and then you have the original blade
trilogy that was rated r and of course
the new blade is coming to the mcu as
well
and fun fact ryan reynolds was actually
in the original blade trilogy
this is awkward so ryan reynolds is
going to go from blade to deadpool to
probably showing up in the blade
franchise as deadpool
and there's definitely going to be some
sort of an awesome joke there i can feel
it
deadpool breaks the fourth wall so i can
definitely feel a joke about him being
in the original blade coming
and speaking of blade the new blade is
coming to the mcu with mahershala ali
and although that isn't confirmed to be
rated r since the original one
was and disney and marvel studios are
going down an
r-rated road it could be rated r and
probably should be rated r
as i've talked about before with blade
comes a sort of
monster verse inside of the mcu this is
going to be a bit of a darker
kind of underground semi-universe within
the mcu
and hopefully this will bring on other
characters and hopefully some of those
characters will go on to form the
midnight suns who i think
a lot of people would also say should be
rated r not to mention
if the punisher comes to the mcu at one
point and
he very much should they shouldn't try
to tone down
the violence because not all of these r
ratings are about
cuss words or nudity or anything like
that i actually don't think marvel
studios and disney will do nudity it's
more about the cuss words with deadpool
and the violence with characters like
the punisher
and really what it's about like i
mentioned is staying true to
who the characters actually are that's
why logan was
absolutely awesome we saw wolverine go
crazy
and tear people apart and then we have
reports of the thunderbolts and the dark
avengers teams coming and these don't
actually have to be rated r
however i do think that some fans would
actually like to see them be rated r
and b some type of a suicide squad film
a
better suicide squad film and watch some
bad guys come together to do some tasks
that the good guys can't get done
now will all of these rated r stories be
a part of the main
mcu stories and affect them yes and no
they will most definitely affect each
other's stories
as in the rated r movies will affect the
other rated r movies but besides that
they will most likely operate like
agents of shield did the events of the
main mcu story affect them but they
don't affect the main mcu story and this
is going to be so that marvel doesn't
have to say to kids
well you have to watch these r rated
movies to be up to date on what's
happening
in the main mcu they did say that you
have to watch the disney plus shows to
stay up to date but they aren't going to
make a bunch of kids have to watch
rated r movies all of the cairns out
there would have complete meltdowns that
would be a disaster but there are a lot
of characters who at their core
kind of require r-rated films to make
the most out of them
and this is something that dc actually
kind of got right
like when they made joker it wasn't
unnecessarily rated art it was very
necessary because of who the character
is
and what goes on in his life how he
becomes this
insane murderer the same thing goes with
the suicide squad that is the new
suicide squad that is coming out that is
rated r
if you've seen the trailer you know what
i'm talking about the tone is already
way different and better than the
previous suicide squad which was rated
pg-13
and then you have movie like kingsman
the secret service which did an
excellent job
and marvel can take note from them as
well marvel studios has done
an incredible job at every single thing
that they've tackled so far i have no
doubt that they're going to handle
deadpool the right way and any other
movie or character that out of necessity
would require
an r rating and there are some projects
coming and it's all going to start with
deadpool so let me know which project
you're most excited for to see coming to
this adult content section of disney
plus
and let me know if you think that
there's a character besides deadpool
that you think should absolutely be
rated r
don't forget to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all of the latest mcu
news don't forget to like the video and
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof